thank God this is like the last launch
for a little while when it comes to gpus
what you see on this table is not even a
third of all the gpus we've retested in
the last month and a half alone anyway
uh this is a twof fur you're getting
9070 XT and
970 uh from AMD in one video because I I
there's just no point in splitting it
into two
[Music]
Hey
Day
d
d what we got work to do yeah I'm
playing World of
Warships World of Warships is the
free-to-play naval strategy game where
you command the most iconic and famous
warships from World War I and World War
II recreate with stunning detail and
accuracy build your Fleet while
participating in various game types
while upgrading your ship's Arsenal
along the way new players who sign up
using my link below will receive an
exclusive starter pack to get you up and
running quickly by receiving 7 Days
Premium Time 1 million credits 300 to
blooms and the tier five premium ship
the exitor so what are you guys waiting
for start syncing ships with World of
Warships by heading in the description
below and getting your
freebies okay so 970 and 970 XT uh it's
interesting this time around because uh
as you can see by some of these other
reference cards on the table from AMD uh
there is no reference card for the uh
9070 series cards uh from AMD this time
around so all of the aib partners kind
of have car blanch to do whatever they
want uh in terms of the designs and such
in fact even the reference spec is
almost more or less a suggestion uh
we'll talk about that in a minute so if
you haven't seen one of our reviews
before uh thanks for coming by I'm J
sense we're going to talk about
performance power draw temperature
generational actually no we're not going
to talk about generational performance
uplift because this is technically I
don't even know exactly which card it
would compare to if you want to know the
truth because the previous naming scheme
was like 7900 XT XTX and then 7800 and
then
7700 and the 970 does not tiar up with
the 77 so the sevens don't match if you
will so essentially all we're going to
do today is just here's where it landed
on the charts and you can see how
depending on the title uh it's very it
very much impacts which cards it sort of
lands against Now cards you're going to
want to kind of pay attention to on the
charts as we talk about them uh it's
going to be like the 7900 XT the 7900
XTX the 570 Ti from Nvidia which is uh
very close in terms of price parody to
the 970 XT but then obviously the
5070 uh when we compare it to the 9070
you see why they named it that way and
they did that on purpose they even
admitted it so that's at least that sort
of makes sense uh anyway 570 Fe on our
chart which is an MSRP card versus the
970 quick silver here which is not an
MSRP card so let's talk about the cards
that we have real quick we've actually
received a few of them but the only two
that have like finished validation and
testing for us is the XFX variants here
which I'm kind of okay with even though
they are going to be some of the more
expensive models on the market um the
white one right here this is our 970 XT
uh that is the Mercury or Merc and it is
the magnetic air version and I was like
what the heck is magnetic air when I
first heard about it well as you can see
you can just pop the fans off they're
just magnetic actually and then the Pogo
pins just contact to a 360 pad that's on
the GPU you might be asking yourself why
would anyone want to do this well I
honestly firmly believe it to be just
the ease of cleaning your fans getting
it out getting more of the dust out um
it's actually a nice feature to have
also too it if they continue to
manufacture these and make parts and
replacement parts for them if you have a
fan that starts to wobble or a bearing
that starts to go bad or any sort of fan
chatter noise that happens over time you
can replace the fan so I've never seen a
graphics card do this before I'm not
saying it hasn't existed I just
personally haven't seen or touched one
uh it's a pretty neat feature in fact
it's pretty nice to where because it's
magnetic it literally just indexes and
puts itself back where it wants to is a
very strong uh magnet uh this particular
card is also a higher than reference
spec what I mean by that is the uh 9070
XT is a 304 wat TDP not 300 not
304 I mean that is oddly specific uh
anyway the 99070 is a 220 watt card but
I point this out because the aibs are
actually allowed to go all the way up to
340 watts uh on their out of the box
specs and we do have a 10% additional
power limit available to us as well but
all the testing was done out of the box
settings with fan curves and power
limits no rage mode or any of that stuff
just out of the box on the test bench
install the drivers and off we go no
tuning no nothing okay so key
specifications here 9070 is both cards
are obviously on rdna 4 we've got
3584 uh stream processors the 970 XT has
496 stream processors uh so obviously
512 more that's that's how numbers and
arithmetic work anyway uh when it comes
to RT accelerators or the same as RT
cores if you will uh 56 on the 970 and
64 on the 970 XT and then AI processors
or like tensor cores which is for like
upscaling and such uh you have 112 on
the 970 versus 28 and the 97 XT and both
of them are listed at having
RS I'll admit I didn't actually verify
that all 128 are there sucks that I have
to do that but what where the
performance is landing I'm going to
assume they're all there um that sucks
that I forgot to do that but just being
fully transparent with you guys I'm not
in the habit of testing the fact that
we're are all the cores and stuff there
that were promised thanks Nvidia uh when
it comes to frequencies though the 970
has a 2070 m game clock and a 2520 MHz
boost clock on a 220 W TDP recommending
a 550 W PSU or higher 970 XT is a 2400
MHz game clock 2970 MHz boost clock with
that 304 WT TDP recommending a 700 watt
PSU but since most cards are going to
actually probably be about 340 watts uh
it's probably recommended to just move
that number to 750 watts when it comes
to recommended PSU now when it comes to
pricing this is where I say it's a
little bit of like wild westcar BL when
it comes to the aibs SCP or suggested
detail price which is recommended by uh
almost said Nvidia AMD uh is set at
$549 for the non-xt and then the XT
being at $599 only $50 of variance
between the Cards most people in the
announcement video felt that that was
too close together given where a lot of
the spec differences are between the two
cards spec-wise they're actually very
similar as you saw both cards are
featuring 16 G bites of
gddr6 uh in fact they're the exact same
memory configuration on both cards I
want to point that out like neither one
gets any sort of a speed bump or a spec
bump when it comes to the memory they're
both 256bit memory buses with a uh
throughput of 6 44.6 gtes per second
exactly the same on the memory so the
only difference is like I said is core
clock and then 512 additional stream
processors found on the XT and then
obviously a handful of more Ai and uh
Ray tracing cores that are on there
so the prices are going to be kind of
all over the place though because cards
can play around with the 40 wat uh well
36 watt additional power limit available
to it the white card that I have right
here which is the like I said the
magnetic air 970 XT from XFX the Mercury
card comes in at
$769 MSRP this is the first time in a
review though I've actually had a brand
tell me what the
worldwide SCP is versus the United
States manufacturers suggest retail
price because of either tariff or no
tariff so$ 769 for the white $749 for
the black it's $20 more for the white so
that puts it at about let's just say
black I I don't I don't think 20 extra
bucks for white is obviously worth it
unless you're building a white build so
let's just say $7.49 okay for pricing
that makes it one uh $150 more expensive
than SCP if you compare like the Nvidia
570 TI at a uh
$749 m SRP but most cards are actually
up over
$900 that's actually a closer to SCP
price for one of the most custom cards
on the market which actually is a nice
thing that that that's kind of sucky to
have it cost so much more but there are
obviously other versions that exist like
the Quicksilver um the black one we have
here is a
$589 uh worldwide S MSRP so that's
making it about uh what 40 bucks above
MSRP that's about the kind of stuff we
normally expect to see with so that's a
custom card Believe It or Not versus the
reference design supplied by AMD so
that's a more reasonable like cost lift
for a custom model with a giant cooler
on here um anyway when it comes to the
estimated shelf price after tariff which
is the first time I've ever had this
figure
$849.99 for this white one right here
and
$649.99 for the 570 Quicksilver 570 damn
it and
$649.99 9 for the 9070 Quicksilver right
here
so there's that when it comes to pricing
so take that as you will anyway um AMD
does say there'll be plenty on shelves I
guess we'll find out tomorrow moving on
to Performance because none of that
pricing matters if you don't know how it
performs so in uh Speedway which is a RT
test remember we've got third gen RT
cores now on 970 versus second gen RT
cores found on 7,000 series The 970
Quicksilver comes in just ahead of the
470 TI tough and literally 13 points
behind the 5070 so not bad at all when
it when it comes to the performance
there the Mercury coming in ahead of the
470 TI super tough uh not a lot but
ahead and a fair ways behind the RTX 480
not surprising when it comes to a pure
RT test there is an entire generation
gap between the two now if we move on to
rasterization performance in our
synthetic here uh in time spy extreme
the Quicksilver comes in ahead by 30
points of the 7900 XT uh at a
12987 and losing to the 570 TI Prime uh
by a few percent and then the Mercury
coming in way ahead of the Prime at a
14703 even ahead of the 4080 super and
pretty much matching the 7900 XTX don't
forget that was a $1,000 card this is a
$700 or $600 card $599 so except that
one's a little bit more obviously moving
on to F1 in 1440 all of my gaming charts
we're going to talk about personally are
in 1440 I think that's where the card is
an absolute Beast uh obviously the
charts that uh we will show that you
guys can look at uh as you pause and go
forward what have the other resolutions
here but our discussion here is going to
talk about 1440 970 Quicks silver coming
in ahead of the 4070 TI and Landing just
behind the 470 TI supertough such a
stupid name anyway moving on the 970 XT
Mercury coming in ahead of the 570 TI
Prime by 3 FPS and losing to the 480
super by 3 FPS not bad if you consider
the fact that this card technically its
MSRP is only 70% of the MSRP of the 480
super although remember this card is a
custom model so it does carry uh a
premium for that moving on to the next
title here let's talk about black myth
uh Wukong uh black myth Wukong 1440p
this is a title that does not favor AMD
I mean you can see that by the th the
the bottom three cards being a 7800 XT a
7900 XT and a 7900 XTX something about
the rdna 3 architecture and black myth
Wukong do not get along however rdna 4
has entered the chat and you can see
there is a a bit of an uplift in
performance versus previous gen for sure
the 970 Quicksilver is just edging out
the 3080 and losing to the 3090 by a
little bit that sounds pretty
disappointing when you'll see what this
these cards due to those particular
cards the 30 series in other games it's
just something about black myth does not
like AMD cards but it's nice to see this
huge gain between rdna 3 and 4 uh when
it comes to this title and then the 970
XT Mercury about 3 and 1/2 FPS behind
the 470 Fe but uh about 2 FPS ahead of
the RTX 3090 so not bad right there uh
if we go and talk about Borderlands 3
badass settings here we know Borderlands
3 loves AMD cards that's why there
should be no surprise that the XFX 970
quick silver comes in right in the
middle of the chart ahead of the 470 C
TI super tough and just behind the 90
7900 XT and then the Mercury is actually
ahead of the RTX 480 and uh just behind
the 480 super so not bad at all when it
comes to that generational uplift
although 7900 XTX is still King when it
comes to Borderlands 3 uh Avatar
frontiers of Pandora another title that
doesn't really seem to favor AMD a whole
lot uh but that's why we have our suite
that we do because it does really show
the strengths and weaknesses of certain
architectures in certain titles so the
970 Quicksilver is well ahead of the
4070 and just behind the 3090 the
Mercury however is just ahead of the 90
or 7900 XT and just behind the 470 TI
tough you can see that 470 TI tough it
seems to trade blows with quite a bit it
kind of makes me wonder if when they
said they were naming these 70 series
cards so that it was less confus
confusing for consumers to figure out
what card it's designed to really
compete with on Team Green you can see
4070 was definitely a card that they
were uh checking out when they were kind
of testing stuff out because of the fact
that uh
5070 wasn't out yet when they announced
all this sort of stuff but if you pay
attention too to where the 5070 is on
these charts and the 5070 TI you can see
it's still holding its own pretty well
against those cards mostly because
Nvidia did not give a huge generational
uplift that we're used to seeing so it
actually fared well for AMD for NVIDIA
to have such a lackluster uplift from
generational uh improvements so I guess
that was sort of fortunate for them
anyway Horizon forbidden West a title
that is heavily favoring AMD and we have
seen this across the board the 970
Quicksilver is just behind the 570 TI
Prime and a fair amount ahead of the
7900 XT and the 970 XT Mercury is
literally exactly the same .1 FPS now we
know that 0.1 FPS is sometimes the make
or break of whether or not a game is
playable but it is 0.1 FPS behind the
RTX 580 Fe in Forbidden West that I that
was unexpected and it is a fair amount a
bit ahead of the b480 super now the
quick silver lands just under the 570 TI
Prime and just ahead of the 7900 XT the
the engine that is used in Horizon uh
definitely likes AMD cards uh cyber Punk
this is going to be a good one we set
our tests up to have a mixture of RT no
upscaling so it's uh no RT Reflections
either it's all lighting Global
illumination Shadows that sort of stuff
no actual Reflections and then uh we do
not do an upscaler so it's really a
horsepower test between the like RT
cores and then the Cuda Cor FL dream
processors to figure out the
generational or comparative uplifts
versus other cards so a pretty decent
jump for the 70 series cards coming from
AMD so the XFX 970 Quicksilver is above
the middle half of the chart coming in
just behind the 4070 TI super tough by
less than 1 FPS behind um and just ahead
of the 4070 TI tough so literally just
splitting the hairs right there and then
the uh Mercury card coming in ahead of
the 4070 TI Tuff and just behind the 480
Fe so in the top half of the card or the
chart for AMD for the first time to be
honest uh when it comes yeah if you look
at the 7900 XTX it's just under the
bottom half of the card so that shows
you generationally when it comes to like
the RT or the ray the ray acceleration
Ray tracing accelerators and the AI
accelerators it bumped it up into the
second half of the chart which is good
to see stalker 2 last title we'll talk
about here um kind of nothing exciting
talk about it's just ahead of 7 the 9070
Quicksilver is just ahead of 7900 XT
just behind 4070 TI super tough and then
the Mercury XT is just ahead of the 7900
XTX and about 6 FPS behind the 570 TI
Prime stalker definitely does favor
Nvidia graphics cards uh but there's
more to talk about here than just
average FPS you'll notice if you look at
these charts closely the 1% and 5% lows
are higher than in as parody cards price
parody card on average now I started
doing some digging for that and to try
and figure out why and there's quite the
story to tell here if we look at F1 2024
1440p ultra high preset with rate
tracing and no upscaling if we look at
frame times alone you can see here the
yellow line which is pretty much covered
by the teal line which is the 57d ti
showing that an average frame time uh at
least the median if you draw an average
line through the the frame times for
those two cards are nearly identical in
F1 and the FPS sort of showed that but
if you'll notice the spikes and Peaks
that are in the teal line in the 5070 TI
shows huge fluctuation between that
average frame time and then the
transient spikes or or lows to be honest
I would even so the lows are the lower
the lowest frame time to meet back to
the average you have highs and lows
those differences right there can
perceive be perceived as Jitter stutter
hesitations pauses depending on how long
that Spike stays uh like it takes to
draw that one frame so if you look at
even the pink line uh which is the 970
uh
non-xt you can see there's a lot less of
those in fact if you want to know what
really consistent frame times look like
we'll take the Nvidia 570 TI uh Prime
from Asus off the chart and this is what
you get you can literally count the
spikes like the big spikes by hand
there's two for the
970 and technically there's three for
the 970 XT but the ones at the start of
the game that's F1 when the when the
race actually starts there's a spike on
every card right there something to do
with the game and the way it runs so
ignoring those there one per card and
they're very very consistent so having
even those lows come up to the average
is better than having a whole bunch of
lows compared to your average cuz again
the difference between the lowest or the
fastest time to draw a frame and the
average that distance is the same as
having it above the average but if you
take away the average now and you just
compare that Gap that's now the
perceived stutter and frame time Jitters
and stuff that people report when they
talk about smoothness of gaming so I
have to say this there has been an
extremely noticeable amount of
smoothness with this generation of AMD
graphics card I also have to say this is
the first and this is the first time I
have had an AMD review with more than
one card even one card or not where I
didn't have some weird game that crashed
or some weird game that wouldn't launch
for some reason or have to reach out to
AMD for help on why I'm getting some
anomalous behavior in some certain title
or a game just refusing to launch
entirely like this is the first time I
have had some of the most Pleasant
review experience of a graphics card and
this is not just AMD this is including
Nvidia and I'm not just including this
generation which we know for for NVIDIA
has been a show I'm going back to
the beginning of starting YouTube I have
never had such a smooth experience when
it comes to AMD graphics cards now I
wanted to make sure that this wasn't
just like a cherry-picked title like oh
f124 is just super favoring the Nvidia
or the AMD cards and for some reason
having all these trans spikes and dips
on the AMD card so I went ahead and
loaded up cyberpunk 2077 in 1440p so all
the same settings we do our benchmarks
with in fact these are the Benchmark
runs right here that you're seeing by
the way this isn't a separate test these
are the actual Benchmark runs that I've
turned into the frame time charts for
you guys uh but this time I just did 970
XT versus 570 TI but again with the
exception of like right in the middle
there that one really big spike which
could be anything those types of
transient spikes happen in every game it
could be something started in the
background of the of the test bench
just about anything could have caused
that and it's really hard to to figure
out what causes one transient Spike it's
when it happens all the time that you
have a problem you got to figure it out
but I want you to notice that even the
Nvidia card that has a lower average
frame rate still has a lot of
fluctuation on the lows as well as some
of the highs so myself personally I
would prefer to have a more squished
average frame time that's slightly
higher than another graphics card that
might have a median line drawn through
their frame time that's lower but with a
bigger range of variance because that
range of Varian is like I've said I'm a
broken record that is what Perce gives
you the perceived stutterin or
inconsistency in the frame rate the
graphics card the 970 XT and the 970
truly felt like it was a higher frame
rate than it was and that's because of
the higher 95th and first or 99th
percentile or first first 1% low and 5%
low frame Ty rates being higher if you
look at the chart ALS so too one other
thing to note I don't have a way to
really present this to you I I I don't
want to have this turn into to be 50
different charts per
review it is the most consistent the 970
XT specifically too is the most
consistent runto run consistency in
terms of the frame rates that we see
when we do our testing out of all of the
cards it's not uncommon to see 1 two 3
sometimes maybe even four uh FPS
variation run to run or to have one card
have a better fifth percentile or one
run have a better fifth percentile than
the other and then another one has a
better first percentile and they just
kind of like whacka all which one has
the worst one I'm telling you right now
the AMD card was like within one FPS
every single time in fact so consistent
I found myself actually running the
tests more than our typical three runs
and some of them in the beginning when I
was validating anywhere between six to
seven runs just because I was concerned
that for some reason I was writing the
same number and not actually opening the
correct test so I would throw them away
and start over and get the same
consistency sometimes only differences
being noticeable in the tenth of a frame
which we do measure down to we measure
down to the tenth of a frame it is
consistent it is actually amazingly
consistent in that Arena anyway here's
one other title I figured okay F1 we
know it does really well cyber Punk we
know that that's there's an RT
discrepancy what about a title that we
know doesn't like AMD so black myth
Wukong is back up here's the frame times
between the 970 XT MC and the 5070 TI
Prime uh you can see right
here if you again there's only a few of
them but if you compare although it is a
a fair amount of average frame time
which also mathematically turns into
frame rate uh is lower and more
consistent like straight line across the
board for the uh 570 TI I want you to
notice though there is actually uh less
transient spikes on the 97 XT MC okay so
last but not least let's go and talk
about power draw and temperatures and
frequencies so in ferar at 4K which is a
very difficult stress test the XFX 970
XT uh is pulling about 350 Watts across
the board through our Hardware
measurement device uh that's including
PCI Express although it's not really
pulling any power from PCI Express um
that's not surprising consider I told
you it's a 340 WT card and there's some
heat and efficiency loss through uh the
operations of making frames happen so
that is what the ACT ual power draw is
from the PSU uh 350 WT so it's it's a
bit of a a increase over say the 570 ti
so if you are like the ultra cons like I
want to conserve all power at all costs
uh the obviously just over 300 watt more
or less 310 watt uh 570 TI Prime is
going to be the more efficient card and
then unless you're like you know what
screw that I want to save even more
power the 970 Quicksilver comes in at
about 2 228 watt uh drawn from the wall
or from the power supply directly now
that's in furmark which is a less than
realistic scenario when it comes to
gaming obviously games fluctuate a lot
so when we move over to cyberpunk
1440p um you can see the 970 XT still
draws 350 plus Watts it's about 352
Watts on average um actually it's pretty
consistent for all three of these cards
pulling the same amount of power between
furmark and uh gaming so this is one of
those few times we actually see the
the figures just carry over to the other
chart usually we'll see some sort of a
drop but that's on the higher end cards
to be honest which don't have to go like
Full Tilt to give you their Max FPS
depending on whether or not there's any
sort of CPU bottleneck or it's fully GPU
bound uh but again just over 300 watts
for the 570 TI Prime and then hovering
around
225 to 300 or 230 Watts uh for the 970
Quicksilver so it's a big Power
discrepancy between the not XT and the
XT let's talk about temperatures real
quick in that same firmar test there's
something interesting with the
temperature sensor in the 970 970 XT it
doesn't seem to update quite as often
you'll notice if you look at the teal
line here which is the 5070 TI Prime
there's lots of input there's lots of of
data points that will give you a very
jiggly line right that's because of how
quick the card is responding back to the
pulling software saying what's your
temperature the 9070 as you can see is
slightly warmer than the 970 EXT
although the cooler is like a very
similar size it's just not nearly as
dense to be honest um I have no idea
what the thermal interface material is
or any of that stuff I'm not doing a
tear down on these cards but even though
it's a much lower power card it is
warmer than the 970 XT averaging about
53c I say warmer and 53 which is funny
but that's because the SE the 970 XT is
reporting a Max temperature of
47° now this cooler is as big as a
5090 that's why the 5090 is on the table
it is a bit
Overkill 600 watts 5 340 600 watts 340
I'm inclined to believe it's actually
47° I have not put any sort of
temperature probes on there to verify
that but I'm inclined to believe it just
based on the weight and density of that
card alone which is why it is coming in
at a Max of 47° in gaming exactly the
same story but again you can see what I
mean about the up
uh the amount of data points you get
with the temperature sensor on the
Nvidia cards versus this family of cards
that's why it just it's like Boop like a
little heartbeat and then flatten a
little heartbeat but that is the way
that the sensor reports when we turn
export the CSV data so take that
information as you will now before we
move on to uh frequency here I want to
talk about the fan designs here I will
say this the 9070 XT and the mag fans
that are found uh on here actually have
a a fairly Pleasant Sound by Pleasant I
mean they sound like bigger fans than
they are to me it sounded like I had an
air purifier sitting on my desk when it
was at at full speed the
970 Quicksilver fans definitely had a
more turbulent kind of a choppy weird
sound to them like almost like the
blades were moving in some way like it
had a I don't know how to describe it we
have we have some sound profiles here
that you can hear at both 150% but I do
I do feel like the XT with the Mag Air
fans uh or the magnetic fans or magnetic
air it's weird thing to call it sounded
better
so frequencies if we look at f120 24 14
uh 40p again RT High um you can see that
we're definitely fluctuating quite a bit
on the 970 XT but between 2800 and 2900
MHz I didn't put the Nvidia cards on
here because the the architecture is
just so different 1 MHz on one is not
equal to 1 MHz on another so i' just be
comparing apples and oranges so I just
wanted to compare the 970 and 970 XT
versus the numbers that they say are the
base numbers so as we said on here the
90 70 uh has a 2520 MHz boost clock and
we were actually Landing just hovering
over the line of 2500 so we were
actually getting the full Boost clock
the game clock I hate the fact they call
it game clock I just ignore game clock
it goes to Bo boost clock anyway don't
waste your time worrying about what game
clock is to be honest and the 970 XT uh
has a 2970 MHz boost clock uh did not
really ever hit that it actually barely
crossed 97 or 2900 at all
um it landed more or less around 2870
MHz but again that is the Boost clock
that is the max up to and I'm they were
hitting it was hitting power limit long
before that I think if I put the
additional 10% slider I'd probably be
able to hit that but with the game clock
being 2400 MHz we were significantly
above that at over 2800 the entire time
so kind of surprised with how cool it
ran that that means we have to be power
limited on what's allowing that
frequency to not quite hit that Max up
to but if there's one thing we've ever
learned about AMD cards is they
definitely Le lean into the up to figure
when it comes to all of their like
clocks and stuff all right final
thoughts now that we have everybody's
cards on the table the 970 and 970 XT
are very strong competitors the the the
old adage of AMD is good but got bad
drivers whatever uh it's
got I I guess just insert whatever
complaint you have here I've heard them
all I don't think they hold up this time
around
I think what's happened here is NVIDIA
has made such
terrible backward strides in things like
reliability mostly reputation amongst
consumers right missing RS melting
connector still which really is only a
5080 5090 4080 4090 problem it's not
going to be a problem with any of these
cards especially since with the
exception I think the Sapphire card
they're all still standard n or eight
pin uh PCI Express
cables none of the other cards from
Nvidia are pulling enough power to melt
the connector so that aside though
there's still a there's still a fear of
that connector being unsafe right
um the the incredible tax if you will
the the team green tax that kind of is
carried now on the envidia cards it's
hard for me to recommend a 5070 Fe or
anything in the 5070 range or even 5070
TI when I know these cards are in the
the price parody and cheaper and
Performing just as good if not better in
just our titles alone and obviously
there's tons of titles out there that
would that would paint a huge story so
I'm curious as to honestly what some of
the other reviewers are saying because I
haven't talked with any of them about
their opinions on this sort of stuff but
I think the 970 XT specifically is a
very strong competitor it's hard to
recommend the 970 though when
technically it's only $50 less expensive
now when you talk about features like
this this is what drives the price of a
card up these kinds of
features find yourself as close to SCP
six uh six or 599 price point that you
can find on a 9070 XT and don't look
back like when it comes to RT
performance when it comes to upscaling
when it comes to FSR
improvements the Gap is narrow and to be
honest I think AMD is kind of doing the
right thing by sort of focusing on a
smaller family of graphics cards that
are as as strong as they can make them
rather than trying to follow the leader
when it comes to Nvidia and say how big
and expensive can we make but I'll
be honest I do wish there was a 9 8xd
cuz I do feel like that would be some
fun competition if you could launch that
card at like
749 uh MSRP somewhere around there that
could truly cause some disruption but it
doesn't sound like AMD has any interest
in that this time around all right guys
sound off down below and this was kind
of a long one there were two cards to
cover but this is like the grand finale
of graphics card q1 of
2025 it just sort of sucks that it's the
first time I've actually had to talk
about what a tariff and pre- tariff and
post tariff and worldwide MSRP versus US
MSRP is and you know what that sucks big
fat donkey dick